good morning Hank it's Tuesday so in
last week's video I said you'll never
guess where I'm going next and your
lovely wife commented it was a toss-up
between whether you were going to the
dentist or the airport honestly while
the joke's on you Katherine because I'm
at the dentist I've been to the dentist
a lot more than 150 times actually in
the 13 long years since I was standing
on a curb in Chicago reading a novel and
a bike messenger shoulder went into my
face the original fractures were
initially misdiagnosed which led to a
long-term infection in many many
surgeries and quite a bit of ongoing
pain all right I think I've had enough
watching that hi greetings from the
future where I'm in my basement so think
this pain goes way back in fact I
complained about it in January of 2007
in the third video I ever made Hank as
you know I had surgery on my mouth a few
weeks ago I complained about it again a
few months ago in a video when my mouth
was still numb and in between I found
little ways of talking about it without
talking about it like back in March of
2007 I complained about a doctor's visit
that was actually a dentist visit at
which my oral surgeon told me and I'm
quoting him directly here you probably
have nothing to worry about I probably
have nothing to worry about if I
probably have nothing to worry about
then I definitely have something to
worry about uh how right you word me
from the past I should say that person
is no longer my oral surgeon and these
days I have like some of the best
dentists and oral surgeons around I'm
very very lucky to have such incredible
care but it often still hurts a lot one
of the problems with physical pain I
mean aside from the pain itself which
for me at least is literally maddening
is that physical pain is essentially
unsure about like a few days ago my son
was bitten by an ant and after he told
me what happened he said it hurt like
this and then he pinched me he was
trying to shrink the space between his
pain and my understanding of it and
language just wouldn't suffice not
because he's six but because language is
always inadequate in the face of pain
but of course being pinched doesn't
really help you understand the pain of
someone else's ant bite either it's very
very hard if not impossible to bridge
that empathy gap I've talked before
about Elaine's scar is brilliant book
the body in pain which was first
recommended to me by microd Mehta in one
famous passage of the books Kearney
writes to have great pain is to have
certainty to hear that another person
has pain is to have doubt in that
respect and many others physical pain
can be profoundly isolating no matter
how many similes and metaphors you
employ to describe the pain no matter
how many times you pinch the people you
love to try to get them to understand no
one can ever quite know what it's like
to have your pain any more than you can
know what it's like to have someone
else's pain as a reminder that you are
alone inside your body that no one else
can access your consciousness and that
what you call yourself is at least in
some ways a kind of prison from which
there is no earthly escape and that's
like horror movie level terrifying if
you think about it long enough and
that's how I feel at least when pain is
turning the inward and inward in an ever
tightening spiral but that's not all
pain can do this is the part of the
video where I generally take a turn
toward hopefulness Hank which is
challenging when it comes to chronic
pain but I don't think impossible
I guess that's easy for me to say
because again I have excellent care and
I don't live in constant pain I don't
want to be clear I don't subscribe to
the notion that suffering is somehow
ennobling it sucks but I do think when
you find yourself able to turn outward
knowing pain can help you be much more
empathetic which in turn helps us to
alleviate each other's suffering because
sometimes listening generously to people
in pain and believing them can be very
good medicine so Hank
nerdfighteria thank you for listening
Hank I'll see you on Friday